[Music]
welcome everyone to the games you should
know class I'm grand master Eric Hanson
my final day in this long month that
I've been here in st. Louis doing the
Grand Master in residence and I'm going
to cap it off with a selfish choice a
game you should know my own from this
year Tata Steel Tournament in the
Netherlands and was in the final round
of the B group which I participated in
in January I was playing former top 10
player Ilyas nearing of Israel he's from
an older generation I believe he is in
his late 40s now and he's still quite
highly rated to 20s around 26 70 to be
exact so still topped top 100 players
still you know close to 2,700 and in
this moment it was the final round and a
win for black for him would have
potentially given him first place
everything was unclear I was a little
bit behind that was on +2 so I had 7 out
of 12 I didn't have a chance for first I
had a chance for a good result but he
had a chance of first in first place in
his tournament qualifies you to very
prestigious a group which is pretty much
the main reason people play in the B
group it's that's an opportunity of a
lifetime I've played smear in a few
times actually and actually it was our
fourth encounter and in my career I
haven't played very many really strong
grandmasters multiple times it's very
rare that they would have come to Canada
multiple multiple times that's not good
for your chest and I didn't you know I
didn't live I hasn't been professional
or lived in active tournament areas with
a lot of strong players for a very long
time I'm still pretty green so he's the
player I've actually played the most who
you know consistently very strong
divemaster
the last time we had played at the
Olympiad I won a game against him icky
game in the Canada Israel match in 2014
and sort of the background story about
that is we both play the same opening as
black we play the Sicilian con variation
which is relatively rare at the stronger
Grandmaster level were to the top
practitioners there and I played white
and he played it as black and I ended up
crushing him in that opening had some
good preparation due to the fact that I
played it as black and I was worried
about some line that sort of used used
some of my knowledge there to my
surprise when we played in this round he
decided to repeat the opening so I went
for c59 m3 e36 the real surprise to me
is not that he's afraid of a fight he
plays very dynamic chest no matter who
he plays doesn't go for a draw not
afraid to lose which is one reason why
he's been quite successful on the
American open circuit but the real
reason I'm surprised is that he had
beaten two strong young grandmasters in
the tournament with black already and he
did both of them with black against e4
and he chose the modern defense so I was
surprised that he didn't play the modern
because he had done well with it instead
he goes back to the kind stubborn and
ensuring a fight sort of sort of saying
you know maybe it was a fluke that how
you beat me last time I'm going to I'm
going to repeat it and come up with
something I leased out that was my
thought so d4 CD 494 86 this is where
the con starts and I decided to deviate
I figured that he last time I played him
I played see for a sort of Marazzi
structure
and I figured he had prepared something
I thought that was logical say say for
safe assumption and because I play the
opening for both sides I do have a few
different weapons available but I didn't
expect him to play the kind I really
didn't expect that and the final round
of the event was in a more in the
morning so there wasn't really
preparation so I just decided to play
Bishop d3 at the board which is is the
main move but not not what I always play
so he played 97 now quickly and I was
just out of book this was move 5 he
played 97 and because I haven't been
playing much chess
you know partly because I'm in st. Louis
so much the sidelines I don't happen too
much because I play less now I I don't
necessarily forget the mainland's
because I still play a little bit of
chest and I'm more likely to encounter
the main lines or Semien lines in other
games but when I'm not active I mean my
memory for some of these obscure lines
is going to you know I'm not reciting
the lines because I'm not playing
there's no incentive so after 97 I I was
out of book I've seen it before but I
couldn't recall anything and I'm just
the good thing about that was his choice
of opening indicated to me he wanted to
beat me also the round was in the
morning and I didn't get a lot of sleep
and I didn't know theory here all three
of those factors did led to me feeling a
strong sense of adrenaline that you know
this guy Canton coming to like like kill
me like I mean like you know when this
game was black win the tournament
I'm have to sleep I can't recall
anything I have to rely on on instincts
so that was good because it was a bit of
a wake-up call so 97 Castle I thought
that was logical I mean 97 I know the
purpose they generally follow up with 96
and then they can recycle they can take
back with a night and that
you know it seems like fairly natural
development that's at least how I could
rationalize it
so castles Knight dc-6 and so I played
93 because I don't want that 97 to find
this suitable square on c6 he's already
got a knight there he's got to find
figure out what to do with that night on
e7 the downside is the nen on b3 isn't
that effective
I'd much rather it be centralized but
keeping all the pieces on the board he
said he wants to have an interesting
game I'll given it will keep all the
pieces on yep yep I could have also
played nine of three I mean in my mind I
could have played anything because I
didn't know what I was supposed to do so
you're not going to go really wrong here
it's not like if I'm not stopped I was
gonna have a really bad position but
Knight f3 also is possible the reason I
went for 93 but they connected to a few
moves I had in mind
when I played 93 I realized this night
on you 7 needs to find a home because
black can't complete development without
it so I had a feeling he might be
applying to place something like 96 so
if I have my knight on f3 or night on b3
which one is better games 9 on g6 and I
thought my knight on d3 after 96 I can
maybe play f4 and sort of pressure it
like that but yeah Neto and after we
could have been played as well one other
side benefit of the night on b3 in the
cons is sometimes white goes for a4 a5
and then item b3 supports that you know
we can get up on an a5 we can maybe get
our Bishop to e3 there's some tender
dark squares in blocks set up so just
seemed like the more natural reply to me
he went 96 did I realize that this
moment that I've looked at this position
a little bit and g6 has been played
before by a few strong players and it is
the main move an example of how to play
this
courtesy of yasser if we go back a
little bit to when he was an active
player he had a game year as black and I
went c4 he played sorry went 8 for
Bishop g7 a5 white win for the planet or
talked about which seems very natural
but after d5 black had a fairly
comfortable position Knight B to Castle
c3 c5 Yasser equalized here this is a
game from 87 I mean I see a nice Center
pretty natural development block seems
to be very okay here
so g6 has been played and one of the top
junior players in the world are 10 me
out from Russia
who's rated as of today around 2,700 and
he's still under 20 he's like 26 98 or
99 he plays this as well so it has a
couple followers with this plan of
trying play Bishop g7 and quickly push
d5 anyone for 96
and okay I went for a Fourier
sometimes there's a there's a couple
ideas with a four I said you can push
the funny five maybe I also will
consider developing my night from a
three to c4 and there it also has some
access to some attractive squares
I was just relying on some previous
pattern recognition of positions that
were similar but not exactly the same
goes b6 topping a five and that's that's
the natural reaction because you can you
know you can imagine if this bond gets
to a five and I can get a piece on b6
that's really going to clamp block set
up
so after D six here okay I thought I got
a four block out D six that's a pretty
decent trade but I can't really progress
further on that side of the board I mean
I can't play a five yet and I'm not sure
I really want to prepare I decided to go
for f4 and my idea behind f4 was back in
2012 I was playing in Argentina and I
played black I played the kind there's a
five man elimination round robin for
four spots
it was the continental championships so
four spots for the World Cup and five
players we all tied for it so four of us
would advance the one player wouldn't so
it was definitely very intense
I was playing American Grandmaster
shavelev and I played the con so I
played with block did in this game and
he actually he went for a setup without
four he went this should be three in the
game he brought a knight to d2 he played
Queen f3 any queenside castle castle so
it was a little bit different but I
remember having a great difficulty
dealing with that tonight and I got
crushed it was a rapid game a pretty
quick game I still ended up qualifying
through another game but I got crushed
that game and I thought that it was a
pretty effective setup I was just with
trying to recall memories or setups that
I could potentially utilize from my own
experience playing
opening a lock so I decided to go for
here I thought that that Mike might make
a little bit of sense I'm going to play
f4 going to pressure this a little bit
develop the Bishop to e3 that seemed
like the most natural square and then
put my knight to be two then maybe my
knight can jump to c4 I'm not sure but I
decided to try that setup anyways
there's a game in this position with
current world champion Magnus Carlsen
before he was a world champion he played
this set up his block and after he was
playing Pater like oh like Oh had white
and after 93 b5 Laco went for Bishop e3
there should be seven f4 castles Queen
age v g6 White had a bit of an edge in
this game just doing more space just do
the more space have some natural moves
coming a little bit of pressure on the
Kings side okay when you play this
opening you sort of accept that White
has a bit more space but let go did
achieve a bit of an edge here from this
game in 2008
so I deviated a bit from that game so if
we go back dr. Bishop III went for d6
and now I played c3 these not played c3
is I just wanted to stop block from ever
getting ideas to play night before
as I mentioned earlier smear needed to
win this game and I was having a good
event I didn't have a chance for first I
was going to take my chances but let's
say they if the game was a draw it was
still a pretty successful event on my
part I thought there was a lot more
pressure on him to push this game and
based on our previous games I know that
he'll plays some suspicious moves just
to January winning chances and even
though I'm mainly a positional player
when I play white I love sharp positions
so I was waiting for a moment in this
game where he was going to lash out
right now he's gone for a pretty
flexible set up but at some moment I
really thought he was going to be the
aggressor and I don't think he's well
positioned to be the aggressive here
White has more space maybe a little bit
ahead in development so I was just happy
to continue progressing like this
council that's one reason why I played a
move like c3 rather than c4 just giving
him less targets making him try to
create targets and take some more risk
so Knight to d2
it should be seven I mean all these
moves are very natural for Sicilian
there's just one thing that's odd to me
does not on g6 I'm not used used to a
knight on g6 I'm not sure the some of
the details behind it it doesn't seem
like a good piece to me doesn't have any
good squares the knight is usually on f6
where it does more in the center and it
can also you know connect the other
parts of the board pretty quickly so my
impression was this is a little bit of a
worse version than an almost Sicilian
whether it's a knight or for the time
man over a lot of the Sicilian lines
that on g6 I don't see what are you
achieved from the opening by doing so
but as I sat here and I thought started
realize some of the points behind 96
I've developed okay my four minor pieces
and now I want to get my queen and my
rooks into the game and as I showed in a
Lego game white played Queen h5 and that
was very tempting when h5 was the first
things I looked at then I was trying to
figure out how does black you know make
use of that night on g6 which positions
does it make some sense and I was
looking at Queen age five and I saw well
I'm actually threatening right now to
you know if you doesn't do something
that Center maybe I'll just start rook
lifting and just check me at him it's
going to react right away he's not one
to sit back Queen age five e 5 ok e5 you
know what that's about
I'm not really going to take you five
and give tonight a fantastic square on
g5 is not a g6 live and elbows f5 makes
the most sense is that night going to h8
or does black have something else here
keep in mind smearing is one of the top
Kings Indian players of in modern chess
so sacrificing material is not a problem
for him he plays the Sicilian he plays
the King's Indian and I know that
because I've seen many of his games
you're playing for a win
you've block you need to create chances
create positions that allow a lot of
possibilities when nh4 we have to be
very quick because after net age for if
I play g3 your Knights trapped so I mean
not the pea sacrifice potentially there
does need to be a bit of serious
calculation behind 9 to f4 yes and as I
said Spearin specialty is he really
understand the dynamic chest so 9 f4 it
should takes F 4 let's look at that
direct line they should have for e4 work
out for let's say 95 that's not Sicilian
elbows some other moves here you know
also maybe something like Bishop g5 but
let's just say 95 I have to move my my
bishop or or bring my Queen backs maybe
move like rook e8 maybe move like Bishop
g5 but Black has two bishops great
squares for them my pieces are a little
bit clumsy
I mean Knights aren't very good in open
positions my bishop is blocked by my own
pawns for the price of a pawn block is
getting a lot of counter play rook e8 d5
great bishop great night actually great
two bishops
I think this is a position that I would
really practically and objectively have
some troubles controlling some really
good squares for black for the okay it's
a pawn but there are so many pieces on
the board yet I'm not going to really
feel the presence of that bond for a
long time actually when I saw this
position I realized started panic
because this is not what this is exactly
the sort of position he specializes in
and to play for Windows black to get
this position this is this is what you
want the most natural move wasn't
working out for me
well there was another move that he was
sort of baiting me to play you know I I
would say that I had some pawn guarding
tendencies these days after spending a
lot of time with yasser and and i was
staying in the same hotel as him that
whole tournament for the whole month and
you know whenever we analyze he'll often
point out the line you know maybe you
could have taken that phone well we look
at this position over here usually the
night is on f6 in the Sicilian and as a
result of d6 pawn can always be
reinforced with the maneuver Knight to
d7 because the knight on f6 and they can
go back to d7 in this position I was
tempted to look at nine to c4 because I
got a bishop on that pawn in a net on
that pawn none of blacks pieces can can
protect the side of the Queen so blacks
only move here originally is okay you
can't defend it move it
b5 now I was like okay after b5 i play
96 with temple attacking the rook the
rook moves out of the way and i take on
b5 a b5 Bishop e5 and I'm a pawn to the
good as he he would say this is a this
is a pawn and I mean it's a I mean it's
going to be a passed pawn it passed be
fun I thought this was fantastic for
white so I started to get very excited I
mean it looks a little bit I mean are
three pieces on the B file here but this
Bishop doesn't really have anywhere to
go wherever it goes I'm going to be able
to take with my knight
so you can't really take advantage of
placement of my minor pieces there
but this is here and we're talking about
so every time I think I see a good line
I have to look for something that looks
a bit crazier than that that seems to
pass that he's not going to roll over
and give me a pond so forcing me to
calculate a lot can anybody guess what
mr. smearin was preparing for me after
94 well fortunately for me I did spot it
and I don't think such a strong player
would allow that d5 of course breaking
in the center whoo so if I go for that
pawn Knight takes c6 d4 and of course
there is chaos in the position but it's
not favorable for white any of these
complications I can't take on d4 because
Queen takes p6 wins the piece and my
dish is hanging here so you know whether
it's
I don't know I mean queen dex t69 bishop
on g3 is hanging by take the rook
they're going to take that key dark
squared Bishop and then it on the 8th is
wrapped two pieces for a rock in this
sort of open position is you know
definitely favorable for the minor
pieces t4 nice move but the dollar move
I have to consider Bishop takes b6 I
attack the Queen the tempo just take on
c4 and after Bishop takes d8 look at
takes d8 I have won a queen for two
pieces but I got a third piece hanging
right now and I would say this is
unclear but I would prefer to have black
probably very active I don't really have
a good way of pushing these pawns
they're actually just going to be target
for the targets for the minor pieces if
I ever play at five one Knight gets to
jump to e5 if I ever play d5 this Bishop
becomes good I think I'm probably going
to go for the amount of pieces okay
maybe here this needs to be calculated
Bishop takes e4 Brooks takes d1 rook a
takes D 1 this is 2 ponds and a rook for
2 pieces however with all 4 pieces on
the board and I think this is kind of
unclear definitely wasn't really
attracted to me if I could trade off
more or create a passed pawn or or
somehow utilize my clean side majority I
might evaluate it differently the rooks
do better against minor pieces when more
pieces have to trade off but with all
four on the board right now and and I
still have my Center pawns a little bit
vulnerable I'm not sure how to evaluate
it but I do put some stock in the minor
pieces with with the other two bishops
on the board and I'm not sure how to
utilize my two extra pounds on the Queen
side I wasn't a huge fan
selling the sort of dynamic position
that I thought he was striving for well
that doesn't work I looked at Queenie to
up Queenie to was a good multi-purpose
move puts pressure on the pond 86 that
rock on a 8 sort of has to stay stay on
guard it also connects my rooks maybe I
bring another book to the e-file or the
default just a nice natural move
well after E 5 f5 again get everyone to
play G 3 I haven't looked at this but
I'm just guessing I mean this is just
the sort of loose position in front of
my King that I'm trying to avoid so I
mean maybe even stuff like f5 I take net
h4 counter play counter play is coming
very quickly that's just a preliminary
line but having that opened you found
having the lines in front of my king and
plus I'm still not necessarily going to
play our 5 next move because I give the
Knights that your goods outpost so g3 is
out of the question
so f5 night up for fish about 4 ef4 rook
up for 95 and again I see moves like
this coming I see outposts like here
White has an extra pawn but it does
install black from getting good squares
for the pieces which i think is an
extremely important factor
yeah I mean he wins games with black and
with white he also loses with both
colors but he's very dangerous on a good
day so I was starting to actually get in
this game I was spending quite a bit of
time in the opening I had burned
probably half my clock on the first 14
or 15 moves and he had been playing
relatively quickly it's because I was I
was just seeing positions I just don't
want I didn't want to have against them
crop up time and time again and I
finally found an idea that seemed solid
Queen f3 and it's similar to the other
moves but how I judged it was how it
deals with this 'if I've move because
the e5 move is what's bothering me the
most because the heat is not a
bothersome move one of my ideas behind
Queen f3 but decided to connecting the
rooks is a gentle move like Queen f2 and
then I can win the pawn cleanly there's
no d5 before like I have a battery Queen
f2 is actually a nice safe move and the
b6 bottom gets gently picked off
well II five is the move that that I had
to spend time calculating after E 5
where I figured it was I can play s 5
and after night at 4 which is what
happened in the game I'm not going to
take I'm going to play Bishop to c2 now
remember my other moves I looked at were
both Queen e2 and clean age 5 which
means my queen would have been attacked
after night at 4 so I don't didn't have
the option just pulling my Bishop back
so clean r3 was a square where I can
afford to do this so that was a big big
difference I knew he was going to play
e5 for whatever reason even though I
assessed it as suspicious in hindsight I
think black can still get away with the
setup or put up some resistance by
playing 98 and 97 so adding some defense
to d6 clearing a path for that good
Bishop on b7 because that was my threat
Queen f2 so I like this I like this
maneuver which is not too uncommon in
some Sicilians or even some Spanish
position also an na 5 was a dynamic try
because well first of all 985 be a
five-block can use the B file and put
the rook there and pressure the beef out
there double pawns but this men a5 move
is not uncommon either in the Sicilian
dragon there are lines where block can
do it and get double pawns and use the B
file yeah it's just a dynamic try it's
not going to be that easy for me to
necessarily attack this pawn on e5 94 is
always meant by something like d5 so
those I think were objectively better
choices but he was pretty committed I
think he had seen a lot of very juicy
lines involving this pawn sacrifice and
I don't blame him the problem is I just
to accept it you know very
understandable he's looking at this they
should be five with my clean out of the
way ninety-five all the positions
opening up tonight's coming here may be
pawns going here I'm being hit with
tempo every single turn I can understand
that you know this is very tempting but
the problem is I don't have to take it
and when I don't take it I have a threat
of g3 getting closer and closer to
trapping that night so in attempts to I
don't know fight off that idea Bishop g5
I go g3 9 h3 check King g2 Bishop takes
P 3 Queen takes c3 Knight g5 h4 and I
just dropped anyways so this moment he
does I mean he does have to go for
something pretty pretty aggressive you
have to complicate things because I mean
you're not really stopping g3 g3 is
coming no matter what and this nights
can be kicked around or trot so he comes
up with d5 and I mean I can give you
guys a few minutes to look at this
position because all of a sudden it's a
very very sharp position g3 doesn't
cropped tonight necessarily it did with
the digibind g5 but keep in mind g3
there's night h3 and Knight g5 and by
adding in d5 he's trying to target my
efore pawn and as a result this long
diagonal so d5 what to do here
things get pretty pretty wild I didn't
have a ton of time on the clock and I
wasn't really interested in getting into
something really sharp
I had to calculate the most direct line
here and I ended up liking continuation
Bishop takes f4 so no I don't want I
don't want to take care give a knight
you know squares to come out and also
I've opened up this is long diagonal my
King a little bit exposed here in some
lines I mean this is still position I
can put my net on e4 and have a nice
square but I still have to double check
does he still have compensation for pawn
sacrifices he did any other lines I
totally agree with that but let's double
check and I looked at it
nope it should takes out four black is
forced take back on that four because if
you throw in it's in between move I can
take back with the bishop and I'm
targeting the knight on c6 so instead he
takes up four so this is very easy to
calculate I was like okay yeah I'm going
to take on at four no not taking on f4
again it slowly starts to get open up
that's not what I want let's look at
taking the d5 pawn first
it takes me five the night has to move
for sure because all my other pieces are
protected I know there's no sort of
in-between move I'm not missing here all
my pieces are very compact my Knights
rendition ninety-five doesn't matter
where that head's going because I can
just fill up the Queen takes out four
and one difference here between some
other lines if you had pushed d5 already
this Knight is hanging now you know
there's no lines of Bishop G size with
the nine protected the Knights not as
good of an outpost as it was in some
other lines so temporarily white is now
up to pawns here two pawns it's going to
be hard to prove compensation for that I
was a bit more confident in my
evaluation with with the two extra poems
so again it's got some tactical issues
that'll move like Queen takes d5 winning
one pawn back it looks like this is a
fantastic very open position for black
some compensation but I have this Bishop
before move again I'm attacking the
Queen I'm going to take the bishop and
the Queen is overloaded between
defending this and defending that
now that's a big problem because that
means you cannot take the second pond
dock you don't want to make a passive
move so for example I mean if you're
playing Bishop about six maybe I can
just play 94 trade off this good Bishop
and I'll be playing upon up at the
minimum at the maximum I can start
considering trying to keep that second
bond look at the minimum so he plays
rook e8 as you can tell these apply who
definitely likes to play you know for
Tempe the key aid is very you know it's
that sort of annoying move to deal with
so the knight cannot really be taken
because of the fish a bit because if
there should be some Bishop c5 check
lose my queen and black is preparing the
play Bishop to g5 and then take this
pawn back and despite being up to pawns
I can still end up in one of those
positions that I really wanted to avoid
it in smearing let's say I try to
protect that second pawn can somebody
guess move that out certain black would
play after c-4 the Moodle messes up the
position I have to calculate a lot a lot
of scary lines and it's just just that
sort of cake chaos I don't want when I'm
just trying to convert a material
advantage
I didn't even calculate c4 when I saw
what block could potentially just pass
him Bishop g5 Bishop g5 is a threat
either way but c4 turn to keeps upon
it's a two-point advantage so Bishop g5
okay I move my cleaner way I'm up to
pawns
I mean Bishop c5 is a good move here but
the move I'm looking for is related to
my c4 Malia
Bishop d6 probably still very reasonable
move I'm probably going to move my clean
out of the way Bishop before well my
name is just still protected
I stopped calculating I'll just say like
maybe those those moves are all good I
got a knight defending this as well you
can take it so Knight takes pawn
so Knight takes e4 Knight d4 let's say
Queen here
maybe I play rook f2 and surprisingly
I'm covering like every single square
now the moves that I saw that caused me
to immediately stop calculating with d5
because that's going to undermine my
entire pawn chain and I'm going to be
susceptible to more checks I saw this
and I knew like I just don't have a good
move I can't continue the pawn chain
every it's going to going to crumble bit
here maybe I have some defense here but
this let's say when I have not that much
time on the clock there's way too much
to calculate here I have to sort of get
this practical b5 okay let's just say
for example a b5 a b5 working a bishop a
date when they take on c4 then d5 is
going to be week I might be left with
one extra isolated B pawn but the
position opens up even more and I don't
think that really favors me this is like
in the hedgehog blacks break against the
hedgehog the maratti structure is b5 so
the general idea is if black can play d5
black should play it so it's just sort
of one of those automatic content it
destroys my my grip so I'm not know
being greedy one pawn is enough I'm
playing snare and so not only is one but
enough let's try to go for an endgame
and avoid some of these lines so I was
very happy with my next move
although after the fact I realized I had
another attractive move as well as six
so let's say black takes on f6 with
addition 94 so our stop Bishop g5 and
threatening Knight takes f6 and there's
no real way to deal with that because
your Bishop is stuck on a6 so
unnecessary it's back on f6 actually
because I still can't take on e5 there's
a problem with that maybe I'm maybe I'm
just staring out maybe after Bishop e7 I
should just bring some more pieces in
that was an alternative well I like the
move I plate they both have similar
ideas they're like white subdue pawns
what's going to give up one pawn to make
the position much easier to control I
went for 90 for stopping Bishop g5 in
preparing f6 so if you want to really
stop f6 you can play f6 yourself but
then we have to call Ben who's somewhere
in st. Louis right now and get him to
yell at me you know this is not pretty
although funny part about it is maybe it
was necessary maybe it was actually
necessary to stop that sticks by playing
at six and this night at least games
another square to go back on so brookey
d1 Bishop takes d5 when I was looking at
this during the game I thought this was
lost because I thought this pin was sort
of forever and I was just going to
double and win it's a very annoying pin
but what I but black does out at least
the resource work 87 or d7 this is a bit
deep but the position does require a lot
of precision from black she's been
playing very speculatively and the after
94 block has to be very precise to to
not end up in a losing pawn down and
game so I'm going to play a 6 no matter
what the flock doesn't do it so one
Queen takes d5 and now f6
you can imagine that smear and being a
very round attacking player wouldn't
find it particularly present a pleasant
for me to give back upon and start
attacking myself a lot of the best a lot
of a lot of very good attacking players
you know don't like being attacked that
much themselves and I'm the same way I
like attacking and I don't like being
flipped necessarily so f6 the funny part
about f6 is it looks like you're great
attacking movement is but after move
like Bishop takes f6 my intention was to
play queen takes f6 and take him into
the end game after gu f6 Knight f6 check
and go into this endgame where white is
up upon with the superior pawn structure
which this should be if not lost very
close to loss one point up clean side
majority and yeah weakened palm
structure on the Kings side yeah that's
94 is very powerful this f6 idea and I
have two knights covering the c5 check
so it's not like black has checks to
throw in or a lot of in-between moves
he played 96 which is happens to be you
know Intermezzo but it doesn't yeah it
doesn't really change anything G takes G
takes f6 here I think he didn't do this
well we end up with something somewhere
in the game I think we transpose to
something similar but that the downside
of that is that five squared gets very
very weak so he 496 I have to move my
queen I moved my queen f2 staying on the
F file because I still want to do Queen
takes f6 after Bishop takes f6 okay I'm
also keeping an eye on c5 and b6 and I'm
making sure my Queens not on a square
that I can continually get harassed by
this night so I did G takes f6 here and
now I came up with the move that I was
very happy with I'd like to say at this
point of the game for the net here until
the very end I was very happy with my
conversion which was it's not something
I can say all most of the time it was
yeah one of my better displays so after
G takes f6 okay first of all you can't
take on our six of the night because I'm
dropping a mate on g2 in the very end of
that line Queen takes f6 Queen takes f6
is is playable but I couldn't resist
seeing this pawn structure and seeing
the squares that were up for grabs
so even though the position is quite
chaotic I had this feeling that you know
what I'm going to take a positional
again I gave back both pawns and now I
got a fantastic night on e for my
bishops protecting it I already see ways
that I can bring my rooks into the game
but one piece I'd like to improve is
that net on b3 and don't see any threats
for black that I was concerned about
so played Knight to d4 and I just want
to you know put that Knight to f5 and
say you know I'm not up upon but your
positionally busted those double
isolated F farms migrate Knights the
Queen on d5 is very very shaky and
something I'd also seen after Knight d4
was I have a to maximize even more this
Bishop is doing a good job of protecting
it but it's not ideally I want to bring
my rook over to the open file which
happens to protect the night
I've centralized my other night and it's
also headed to a really good square
potentially and blocks the diagonal this
diagonal over here but I want to bring
my initial on t2 to b3 so that all my
pieces are coordinated I didn't have
maximum coordination yet and I just had
some sort of aesthetic desire to
coordinate all my pieces once this pawn
structure was shattered so I stopped
looking for like you know checkmates or
you know crushes I started just looking
for full coordination the natural moves
looked 81 I saw one thing I didn't like
about that was clean goes to c4 and
let's say a move like Knight takes f6
here so I kicked the clean off of the
diagonal so that I can go for this this
might still be winning actually I think
it still is because I'm up upon and I
can defend to me but I saw rocky too and
I didn't go any further I can play rook
F to here and I should be out the pawn
and I should be able to trade everything
off I just didn't feel like this was
necessary
so 94 and here was when I first realized
or believed that I was completely
winning and all my moves now were played
very quickly and it was my opponent who
ended up getting into much worse time
trouble we're on move 22 we had to make
it to move 40 I'd spent a lot of times a
lot of time in the first half of the
game but now I saw my plan work
81 bit should be three maybe then I can
take on our six
but I'll maybe movie I move the Knight
to f5 it all looks rosy rook 88 and I
can just say after telling you guys what
I'm planning to do you can try to stop
it but it's very hard to actually come
up with some good moves here so he
played work 88 he had to make a move
rook a e1 because when I get my Bishop
to b3 I'm kicking the Queen off of that
diagonal and then I'm ready to take out
600 that's the best circumstance
possible where I'll have pressure on f7
also have the Queen on f6
which coordinates very well tonight on
f5 and my rooks are ideally place
if I came to s8 now you didn't know what
to do and it's and this is why it's very
annoying what's another reason why I
didn't go for some of the obvious
captures is wearing you're a long time
it's a lot harder to know what to do
when there's no you know the obvious
captures the sequence of moves that you
can rattle out leaving the tension in
the position leaving my nights where
they can go virtually anywhere I thought
was extremely difficult to deal with
practically he just doesn't you know I'm
withholding night ninety takes f6 he
needs to continue making useful waiting
moves which is what I'm doing I'm I'm
improving my position blacks to find
good waiting moves here is very
difficult because this Bishop is stuck
on e7 to defend f6 this Knight is sort
of stuck here as defending the King
doesn't really have any good squares
this Bishop and Queen are there you know
it's not clear what black should be
doing there's nothing obvious here
because I'm leaving keeping the tension
so I was really trying to lay on the
time trouble like that by by not taking
anything he's got to think for himself
every single move so you played King
that fate this should be three dollars
last move that I had planned before I
was going to decide to calculate again
and well at this moment it's it's pretty
bad
like there's not many squares let's move
that Queen you played 25 a couple other
options sacrificing the Queen for a rook
and good night
unfortunately the pawn structure is
still really bad and I can just calmly
continue the attack play h4 kick kick
out the night you'll be bring my Colina
h6 oops
but just a sample line h5 Queen III and
I'm threatening Queen age 6 check King
goes here and if this Bishop doesn't
stay on e4 I'll have the Queen takes g6
that is actually just no moves here this
Bishop this bishop moves that six will
be hanging so black still has to deal
with a winning attack but with a
sacrifice let's just say something like
clean b7 probably is going to take on f6
Bishop f6 clean and 6 let's say rook e1
here I've recovered my pawn if King is
worse than before
my Knights my pieces are all really well
placed but maybe well I assume this is
winning in multiple ways but maybe not
by force maybe I just have to trade off
into a winning endgame up a couple
Pompey 6 is hanging I'm threatening on
threatening 96 check threatening Knight
f5 and Queen g7 mate so yeah this this
also is completely lost but yeah there's
not really any other squares to go with
a queen so you play the only on the move
Queen e5
and I came up with a thought a pretty
nice way to finish the game so I'll
share that with you guys you can find
out how I closed out the game here he
was under a minute
so those Queens on you thought he knows
that you know I can move my knight
somewhere potentially get a discovered
attack so okay my knight is hanging on
e4 right now that leash from p7 is
attacking it I also feel compelled to
punish that Queen for being on e5 when I
put all my pieces where I feel like they
should be yes yeah just Knight takes f6
well 19,000 I'm trying to go into an
endgame because after Knight f6 I'll
block is clearly not gonna go below 6
because then I can take the Queen and
then I can take the bishop because I the
bishop types of standing on 6 because
I've cleaned xf7 mate no it's going to
be clean f6 and you know black is hoping
for an endgame and then game like this
know what white is up upon but it's what
I end up doing forced resignation on the
spot which is sort of why I really like
this game I felt like I put all my
pieces in such squares that he never
gets into an endgame down upon because I
could have been an endgame up upon in a
few different lines and if you played
perfectly okay I have to allow that 9
takes f6 clean takes f6 and sweep down
to 30 seconds
Queens III
yeah but I can't do anything so and he
has no time but he has no news because
of the Queen goes to g7 it runs into 96
check and there's no in-between moves to
throwing here because rook takes f7 you
know I'd like that you know windmill or
whatever that's obviously game over but
there's just no moves like yeah actually
he's not wanting resign early but
there's there's no moves here you can't
throw any pieces into block and you know
you don't have any time to like go into
Bishop d6 because I take on your six you
can't throw and rookie once my Queens
defending but if you go into this I
again have have the windmill and I'll be
out much more than a pawn at the end of
those lines so Queen g3 all my pieces
are at their maximum and he resigned and
that takes my lifetime score gets them
to two wins and two draws to win the
fight two draws is black I have to say
if he didn't play as aggressive as he
does which he does every single game he
might not be in the case but I always
enjoy my games against him and this is
definitely one of my better games that
I've played in a long time it was
thought it was a very very clean game
but I was very happy with the way I
managed to read what he wanted to do and
sort of control the counter play because
there are a lot of positions that I
thought that could get out of hand and
that never really happened and sort of I
use determine situation and you know had
favorable favorable conditions
yeah so yeah this is one of my favorite
games from it probably my favorite game
from like MJ which I played in this year
out of the 13 games I played
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]